how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today we have some leaked videos
from the set of the Falcon and Winter
Soldier and they are very exciting to
watch we have action sequences between
John Walker as the new Captain America
and also Bucky Barnes aka the Winter
Soldier is there as well we also have a
new scene with a female character
fighting u.s. agent and we believe this
to actually be a major character in this
series because we believe that she's
going to be a part of the Thunderbolts
Thunderbolt Ross has Thunderbolts have
been reported to be coming to the MCU
and the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
and the Black Widow movie are set to set
them up and it seems like we may have
our first footage of one of those
characters songbird right here so I'll
break down everything you need to know
about this leaked footage right here but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a black panther Funko pop all you have
to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and leave a
comment about the video down below now
here's the first leaked scene that we
got in its of the new Captain America US
agent John Walker now as you can see
here he is wearing the fool
Captain America uniform and he actually
looks a lot like Steve Rogers it even
looks like he has blond hair similar to
Steve Rogers as well now this may not
actually be Wyatt Russell and maybe his
stunt double preparing for a scene and
as we're about to see he wears his
helmet his captain america helmet in the
scene but he has a full captain america
uniform on but then we have another
leaked video that's of the same scene
it's taking place at the same location
at the same time but it's of the Winter
Soldier fighting somebody
now in this scene we can see that he's
clearly fighting somebody because there
are hostages in this truck he defeats
one of the guys and then he goes to the
back of the truck to open it and let
people out we've kind of seen footage of
this before but from a different angle
but the great part about this is it
feels very Captain America esque the
fighting styles look like they're coming
directly from a Captain America film
which is great because that's really
what people want and remember they're
shooting this like a movie anthony
mackie recently revealed that the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier is going to feel
like a long six to eight hour film it's
not going to feel like a TV show and the
production and the crew even said that
they've never shot a TV show like this
before it's different than anything that
they've done in the past so it's really
going to feel like you're watching a
Captain America movie but let's move on
to this new leaked video that we've got
between us agent the new Captain America
fighting a woman now as you can see
everything in the background is on fire
and as you can see in the background
there are multiple people fighting
Captain America at this point there's
hostages in this van and Captain America
and the Winter Soldier went to rescue
them but as you can tell in this video
Captain America u.s. agent Captain
America is clearly fighting a woman and
who we believe this woman to be is
songbird now we've had other leaked
photos of a woman in the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier Series in the past which
we believe to be sung bird as well the
photos that we saw in the past
definitely have wisdom wants to the
comic book character and the reason that
it's such a big deal that she is
appearing in this series is because of
the Thunderbolts we know that
Thunderbolt Ross is going to be pretty
heavily involved in this show he's going
to be the one to give this Super Soldier
Serum to u.s. agent John Walker now the
Super Soldier Serum is actually and
secretly going to be controlling John
Walker but the point being is that
Thunderbolt Ross is really trying to be
in charge now songbird in the comics
originally starts off as a super villain
but she turns into a hero or at least an
anti villain when she joins the
Thunderbolts in the comics and that's
what we think will happen here she'll
either be caught and arrested and
Thunderbolt Ross will offer her a chance
of freedom if she joins the Thunderbolts
and does his tasks or at this point in
time she's already working for
Thunderbolt Ross secretly because this
event right here with this leaked
footage that we see could be staged by
Thunderbolt Ross we know that after the
events of Civil War he doesn't like not
being able to control the Avengers and
other superheroes and we know that Sam
is not going to take the Captain America
mantle and we know that Bucky obviously
defied him during Civil War as well and
then you taken to the fact that the
Super Soldier Serum that US agent has is
probably mind controlling him and
Thunder bull Ross is in charge of that
this probably all is some type of scheme
to set up Bucky and Sam but more will be
revealed as soon as the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier resumes production which
is said to be very soon so let me know
what you think about this leaked footage
of the Falcon and the Winter Soldier we
saw us agent John Walker fighting with
the Captain America uniform and with
Captain shield and Bucky fighting and
helping as well let me know what you
think in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier and the MCU for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf